hi this is my audition for call her
daddy the podcast
how are you a bunch of [__] buckets doing
one of our readers writes
hey guys love you how long should i know
a guy before i let him come in my ass
and the answer is as long as it takes
him to get hard and [__] you in the ass
i think it's so important to vote if you
are not hot
literally get raped literally that's how
you're gonna get invited to parties
just grease that hole up and let them do
it pep boy style
oh my god so we're doing [__] classes
right now
it's so important that you know how to
suck a [__]
you stupid [__] this is an average [__]
with with like pyrenees disease which
means it curves up
a lot of guys [__] curve up take this
off
the mic is another [__] so picture
there's one [__] getting ready to go
and then you have one [__] right now so
now this is like another [__] it's just
hitting you in the back of the head
okay so you have three [__] at once
three [__] and this is like
whoa
this is what your [__] should look like
after you've been
[__] and then you like [__] throw
it out you get another one
i loved kohler daddy i watched every
episode of call her daddy
that's how i learned how to suck off my
uncle
dave portnoy i don't care what you do
you want to throw me down a flight of
stairs that's fine
you know what's gonna happen at the
bottom of that flight of stairs i'm
gonna come
i don't even care if my neck's broken
i'm just gonna come daddy gang